when i finally went to the music shop to
buy my first guitar
the guy who was selling the guitar to me
he started to draw up all of the
figures on his computer for how much i'd
have to pay and he said to me
now do you want any accessories and i
looked around at the shop and it was
filled with so many different kinds of
things that i could buy for my guitar
and i just had no idea
i had heard some tips from people before
but i didn't really know what stuff i'd
actually be using day to day
so i ended up buying a lot of stuff
which i didn't need i didn't buy some
stuff which i ended up having to buy
later because i did need it
so in this video i'm just going to talk
about some of the gear that i've
accumulated
over time and particularly the stuff
that i actually
have been continually using which is you
know actually helpful to me as a player
so i'll start with uh you know on the
guitar
there's this uh three main things that
you you start with that i've been using
a lot
so the first thing you might have
noticed is um this little black thing
here
now it's stuck to the guitar i know a
lot of people are
not fans of doing that because you know
it ruins the appearance of the guitar
and that kind of thing
i'd prefer my guitar to be useful rather
than pretty
even though it's nice for it to be
pretty as well and what this is is a
pick holder
okay so you can see in here i store the
picks that i i
use on a on a normal basis and um you
can store i don't know
if there's sort of like a spring-loaded
mechanism in there you could probably
store
maybe seven or eight picks quite
comfortably
so i find that really useful because
then i don't need to picks are
notoriously easy to lose
so i don't need to go searching for a
pick when i need one it's right there
secondly um you also obviously need
picks
now i it'll take you a while to sort of
determine
based on the way you play and um the way
you like a guitar to sound
what kinds of picks you need so in
general the thicker the pick is
the louder you can play with it or the
bigger strings you can play so for
instance if you see
picks for a bass guitar they're super
super thick because the strings on the
bass guitar
are super thick um so so play with them
for a while i would advise i mean
they're really they're pretty cheap
between kind of like 20 cents 50 cents
um
if you if you go in and make a big
purchase you can probably ask the person
who's selling the guitar you just throw
in a few for free because
they honestly are they're just plastic
basically um
the the heavier picks will make a
clearer more distinct sound um
but when you're playing softly it's
harder to control them so if you want to
if you've got a
thinner pick that'll be easier if you're
playing softer but thinner picks
obviously
they'll break if you're playing a lot of
rhythm and you're playing quite hard
so that's the second thing that you'll
need the third thing
is a strap um so i i play standing up
quite often and uh getting a comfortable
strap is really really
helpful so obviously before you buy a
strap you should try it on
it will change a bit as you um as you
wear it i mean like for instance this
one's made out of leather
otherwise made out of plastic i would
try and avoid one
where some of the plastic ones they
slide around a lot on your body
and that's you don't want a guitar to
slide around when you're playing because
you want it to position to have to hold
still
you don't have to use muscles to hold
your guitar
uh in the right position you want to be
focused on your actual playing
so uh one which has kind of like a soft
side on it
will be helpful so put one on see if it
slides around when you wear your guitar
and um yeah that's how i would judge
now the the fourth thing i only said
three but uh that's because some guitars
come with this
is um an end pin so right here you can
see
um sort of in the middle of the guitar
basically
there's a pin which i which i put my
strap on
now there's actually two so there's one
here and there's one on the other end
now many guitars come with it but the
first guitar i bought
only had a pin on the end which is where
the lead came out
and it didn't have one here so i had to
get it installed later
now a lot of people if they have a strap
what they'll do is
they'll they'll put one end on on a pin
that might be already here
but because they don't have a pin here
they'll they'll take this end of the
strap and they'll put
they'll tie a shoestring to it and then
they'll tie the other end of the
shoestring
to the top of their neck so it'll kind
of sit across and
go all the way down to the neck and
that's fine i'm a bit scared
of holding up uh an expensive guitar
along a shoestring but i've seen plenty
of people do it
in my experience it sits a bit
differently on your shoulder
i find it less comfortable but maybe
that's because i'm used to
wearing a strap where the m kid is
fitted uh in the middle of the guitar
so if you know that you're going to be
standing up when you're playing
you might as well ask them to most music
shops will install that for you
um and if you're if you're keen and
you've got you know a drill and stuff
you could do it yourself i suppose
but that's really useful to get okay now
after the guitar itself
you'll probably want to store the guitar
somewhere so the first guitar i bought
i um i got a uh or i suppose they call
these a gig
bag so it's it's kind of made out of a
soft material
and it was i don't know 30 or 40 dollars
inside you can see it's sort of lined
with like soft material so that it
doesn't damage the guitar
so this isn't like the cheapest kind of
big bag you can get some gig bags don't
have any padding whatsoever
but i found that i wanted something like
this because i wanted to be able to
take it with me and not be scared that
it was going to get damaged but also i
didn't have the money
to spend on a a proper case which is
what i'm going to show you in a second
and this this protected my guitar just
fine for a good
eight or nine years or whatever it was
and so uh
if you've got one which is soft on the
outside but as long as it's padded on
the inside
you'll have no trouble and the important
thing is as well is that it has lots of
sections where you can put stuff i'll
show you some of the other little bits
and pieces
where you don't want to have to uh have
that in a separate bag
it just makes sense to keep with your
guitar and to make sure it doesn't get
lost
now
a hard case on the other hand uh this
will set you back
uh anywhere between 100 and 200 dollars
i suppose you can get more expensive
ones but i don't think there's that much
difference
some guitars uh for instance for
instance a maintenance guitar uh this
is this is the guitar i was holding just
now um come with a hard case because
because they're hard the interior it
doesn't
it's it's not necessarily going to fit
every single guitar shape out there even
though most of them are very similar
so some guitars will come with one but
others will not
um so if you've got the the money you've
saved it up
it is a worthwhile investment um it's
obviously a lot more sturdy
and even though the soft case the um the
geek bag
has protected my guitar the bag itself
has taken quite a beating whereas this
is
far more durable so if you're buying out
if you're if you're buying your first
guitar
um you know it's it's really up to you
in terms of how much money you've got i
thought that did the job fine for many
years
but if you know like you're interested
in doing this long term then
this is the way to go
okay now moving on there's all kinds of
other bits and pieces that you can get
okay
so i think the first place after all of
that sort of external gear
that i would go to is um a capo a
c-a-p-o or
carpo or i actually have no idea how
it's pronounced um so a capo
what's it for this funny shape is to
help you change the key of the guitar
so for instance i can play in the key of
g right now
and the key of g is often the first key
that
guitarists learn because most of the
major chords don't have any barre chords
in them which are hard to hold these
these kinds of things
um but if i if i put a caper on say at
the second fret
and i play the same chords but further
up
they're all going to be up one two
semitones so now i'm playing in the key
of a
even though the chord shapes i'm making
of the key of g
so uh akibo is really i i think it's an
essential
for a guitarist um i'm not sure how many
songs you can play with that one a lot
of
songs are written in open chord form so
they don't need a capo
but plenty of them do now the capers are
all different i've got
a four here so this is the one that i
normally use
let me slap that there this one's a
little bit fancier the springs kind of
loaded in a different position
but it's not as heavy so i use it for um
i tend to use it on on higher strings
so that's one which is nice slap that on
there
uh this is this is an interesting one
which i kind of never got
the hang of uh but it doesn't uh it
doesn't have a
the same kind of spring mechanism so you
you sort of close it like that and then
it stays put
so you can you can slap that on like so
there we go and um this last one this is
a really
kind of clever one this doesn't have
springs at all so
most of these you can see once i
i can expand it so that i can fit the
guitar in and then when i release
it goes smaller and a spring is what
holds it tight
and obviously the longer you use it like
that spring will weaken and that kind of
thing
but this one this one is fancy it's hard
to show you from far away
but it just uses a sort of um
well there's a spring actually holding
that out but it's not a spring holding
it in place
so i use this one i often use it upside
down actually so i can keep
one string open but anyway i'll talk
about that a bit more when i look at
other keys
now a capo will be anywhere between sort
of 20 and 40 dollars
and um it's it's really it's really
essential i think so
you might as well grab one there are
pretty plenty of good brands out there
i would uh generally avoid the ones that
use a
um that kind of strap around rather than
using a spring
you might be able to get away with one
of those using a nylon string guitar but
with a steel string
i find that there just isn't enough
tension so it doesn't hold on to the
strings hard enough
when you wind it around so if you play
really loud um the strings will buzz
continually so uh they're okay i suppose
if you're playing softly maybe if you're
finger-picking
but general playing i'd go for a
spring-based one
okay next uh these are sets of strings
so you've got six strings on a guitar
and
uh just you know over time they will age
and they will lose some of their volume
and their tone
and also some will snap so depending
like if you play really hard that kind
of thing
so i find the the three most common
strings
that snap are the d
and g in the middle of the uh of the
guitar and that's probably because
if you can see they're going the
furthest i don't know i mean they're not
held at the highest tension because
they're not the highest notes
but they just break really often um and
also this um
the top e string the highest note uh
because often when people
are strumming uh on their up strums
uh when they play is
that that up like that um that's that
top e string is taking most of the um
most of the force i suppose and it's the
thinnest string as well
so even though uh this bottom e string
also gets a lot of force applied to it
anytime you're playing like a down
rhythm like this
because it's it's so thick uh it's very
rare i think i've
um i mean i've broken dozens of strings
and i've maybe broken the e string only
only once um so anyway the bottom e
string i think
so you're gonna often be replacing these
strings and sometimes after a while you
just want to replace
the lot so i find it's really helpful
these are
these are sets of six strings each you
can buy them in different
weights so some of them will be heavier
which means you can get
louder sounds out of it and some people
say the tone is better other ones will
be lighter so they're easier to hold
down
but you can't play as loud so i
generally tend towards the lighter end
of the spectrum because
when i'm playing i tend to be amplified
so i don't need i don't really need that
volume and i'd much rather be able to
hold the strings down easier and move
between my chords
faster so what it boils down to is
uh try a few out there sort of between
20 and 60 dollars a set um
i i tend to go somewhere in the middle
like about 30 dollars my ears are not
that great i can't really tell i once
bought a really
expensive set of strings and i couldn't
tell the difference so
try them out uh if you're unsure start
off with lighter strings first
especially if you're learning because um
the heavier strings will really cut into
your fingers
and um they'll really hurt also do you
i mentioned that you know some strings
break more frequently than others
so you can buy individual strings so as
well as a set
when i played a lot i often used to
carry around a lot of
the extra d and the g because i knew
that they would break
and i didn't want to crack out a whole
set just to replace a single string
so you can also get some singles as well
all right what else um okay here's a
lead uh
which is for plugging in uh to a speaker
i don't own an amplifier so i don't know
nothing about them
but a lead is really essential and take
care of your lead as well make sure it's
um it's wound up properly and all that
uh okay i just talked about restricting
just now so i'll show you these two
uh first i have a screwdriver the reason
why you want a screwdriver is because
if a if a string breaks for instance so
suppose
my top e string snaps um what will
happen is
it'll still be attached to the guitar
it'll be attached here
at the um closer to the bottom of the
guitar and it'll still be attached at
the neck
okay so in order to get the street out
so you can replace it with a new one
these little sort of pins in here they
need to be priced out
so i use a i use a screwdriver and i
just don't
lever them out because they held in at
quite a lot of tension so the guitar
string doesn't just pop out when you're
playing
so that's that's for one side for the
other side
um you use this now i actually have no
idea what this is called
um but what it's used for is for winding
these um machine heads which is what
controls the tension of the string
winding them really fast now i'm not
going to do it with my current strings
because my guitar is actually tuned and
this will put my guitar attitude it
might even snap my strings
but if you can imagine when you're um
first putting on a new stream you have
to wind it a long time
um in order to get it from you know no
tension to really high tension so it
makes notes
like that um so it takes forever if
you're just doing it by hand
whereas this it just goes around and
around and around and it just makes it a
lot faster
if you're doing one street you probably
wouldn't notice but when you're doing
six strings
um when i used to before i got this when
i
uh would wrist your guitar it might take
me oh
maybe half an hour and part of it was
just because i had to turn the
machine heads for such a long time
whereas this i could do it in probably
10 minutes
okay so just it only cost like five
bucks
it's a very useful tool
now okay what's this uh batteries
batteries so if you have a guitar that
has a pickup in it so you can plug into
an amplifier that kind of thing
most likely it will have batteries in it
that power the pickup and send a signal
out to the amplifier
so uh you want to make sure you have a
spare set with you
this particular guitar uses double a's
which is nice and standard
the previous guitar i used had a 9 volt
battery but in my experience
batteries run out at only the most
critical moments they don't run out when
you're practicing
and um it's okay you can go buy a new
one they run out right in the middle of
a sole
and it's it's it's not nice to have a um
a guitar start crackling and popping on
you because
the pickup is running out of battery so
always have a spare with you
if your guitar needs one okay
what do we got here all right so um i
think i mentioned
in a previous video that my first guitar
had a tutor in it
this one doesn't so you can get a couple
of different kinds of tutors now
this one is a um it's a it's like
what's it called well it's it says
chromatic tutorial but what it does is
you
actually put it onto the guitar it's
really clever
and um you turn it on you can see it
just there
and when you play a note what it'll do
is it'll pick up the vibrations from the
guitar itself
and it'll tell you if those vibrations
are right and if you have to tune up or
down
okay so that's really cool uh but
you know cheaper sort of tutors um the
older ones
are based on a microphone so you would
sit the the tuner right next to your
guitar next to the sound hole you'd play
a note
and it would listen um if you've got a
smartphone
you get apps that will do that as well i
suppose the only disadvantage is if
you're in a
really loud room you're playing with a
band and everyone else is practicing and
you're trying to tune your guitar up
it sometimes has trouble picking up the
sound just because there's so much noise
in the room
so um these are often useful for that
and this they're smaller as well
now while i'm on the topic of tuning um
this is called a tuning fork now i'll
talk about tuning in one
depth later but um
excuse me a tuning fork is useful if um
you want to tune and you don't have one
of these or just run out of battery or
something like that
the way it works is if you strike it
it'll resonate at a certain frequency
this is an e 2d fork i have an a
somewhere but i don't know where it's
called so if i strike it
i'm just going to put this down for a
second
you want to strike it quite hard a handy
place to strike it without you know
hurting other people or damaging other
objects because metal
is the sole of your shoe so if you do it
like this
you can probably just hear that but what
you basically want to do is put it to
your ear and it'll make
an e well for this 2d4 it'll make an e
note and when you listen to that you can
tune your guitar according to it so you
can't hear it when i put it next to
my ear so i'll put it next to the mic
and you could hear what it sounds like
there we go
okay so i think i think you probably
could have heard that so that note is an
e
and you you play that enough times and
you can hear it and then you compare
that to what your guitar is playing
okay so that'll help you tube all right
now i think i think this is the last
piece of gear that i'm going to show you
yeah
um if you are going to be playing in a
band or something like that
um uh or i played for church fruits
you're going to be the position where
you're playing guitar and then you need
to put it down um for a little while
then you come back to it
and so on so you could just put your
guitar on a chair
or on the floor but it's a bit
precarious so what might help is a stand
now there's lots of different kinds of
standards um
i kind of like stands like this i've got
a couple i'll show you
um that fold up really nicely so they're
compact so it's easy to bring with you
um you can fit it in a gig bag or in
whatever bag you've got so
because they're small what they do is
they are they unfold
like this and you can adjust it for
you know the size of your guitar
surfaces if you've got a smaller guitar
you bring the legs in
and then i just sit on top like that
okay so
uh that's that's much more uh safe and
sound than just putting on the floor
putting on a on a chair i've seen
guitars fall off chairs and clang and
you lose your tuning and so on so a
stand is really helpful
um this this stand is pretty old so it's
kind of damaged which is why a piece
just fell off it
but they cost i think this one cost like
20 bucks so it doesn't need to be
flashy it just needs to sit there and
support your guitar so if it does that
this one over here i'll show you is is
slightly fancier
because it's a it's a bit it's a bit
smaller and the
the legs are kind of let's see how does
this go
they're kind of um more sophisticated in
the way that they they fold and that
kind of thing
but they're all basically doing the same
thing one of the greatest things about a
stamp
particularly when you're starting out uh
learning to play guitar
is that you can just sit in your room
and it makes your guitar really
accessible
because rather than unpacking everything
getting your
case out and all that kind of thing
which takes time if you just got a
couple of minutes you can just pick it
up
you know strum a few chords play a quick
song or something like that and you put
it back down and it's not a big time
investment
so if you're learning the instrument
everything you can do to make it easy
for you
to get a few minutes in here and there i
think is valuable
so anyway um that's all of the the gear
that
i i really actually use i've got a few
other bits and pieces
um like i got a cloth and some oils and
that kind of thing which for maintenance
of the guitar
but i don't use them very frequently and
um in fact you can sort of get away with
most of your everyday
everyday playing without using those so
these are ones i found useful